brazil committed to Jesus
it has the largest Catholic population
in the world but maybe not for much
longer an enormous Pentecostal church in
Western Rio de Janeiro is staging a mass
event more than a thousand people will
be baptized this morning it wasn't so
long ago that more than ninety percent
of Brazilians considered themselves
Catholic today a quarter of the
population is Protestant most of them
are members of the Pentecostal movement
and call themselves evangelicals
Oh
they sing the praises of Jesus their
Redeemer
ah
oh I want to become a new person start a
new life meet Jesus today we're moved by
the message that transforms people I
believe that Christ is the Redeemer
many people here used to be members of
the Catholic Church but that church
seemed remote to them the charismatic
leader of the Pentecostals sillas
nullifier is different
I respect about this role might respond
CBP opposite the church transforms
people those who lived a depraved life
will change that they'll marry and lead
virtuous lives those addicted to cocaine
will break free that is the power of the
gospel this church is affiliated with
the asamblea de Deus the assembly of god
which boasts 12 million members it's not
only the biggest Church in the
Pentecostal movement but one of the
largest Protestant churches in Brazil it
embraces thousands of parishes across
the country malla fire has given his
church the added name Victoria and
graceful victory through Christ do you
have a cadet church's money is invested
in missionary work in in building new
temples that's expensive that's why the
assistance will now take up the
collection may God bless each one of you
and multiply everything you have the
Bible promises generous people
prosperity here the theology of
prosperity is preached believers have to
donate a tenth of their income and make
additional donations at every service
some pay by credit card especially
larger sums the more you give the more
God will reward you that's the message
that summer horse knows we are receiving
these new soldiers of Christ into the
church from today i represent not just
my life but I represent I the Church of
Jesus amen
they come from all walks of life some
app or others belong to the rapidly
growing new middle class the millions of
Brazilians who have only recently
escaped from grinding poverty they are
seeking spiritual comfort and material
prosperity
eight pastors baptize people
simultaneously in a pool malla fire has
increased the membership of his church
by more than three hundred percent in
just five years he now has more than
50,000 followers in some 100 parishes
his ambition appears to have no limits
he aims to open a thousand new churches
for many more converts from Catholicism
cathodic when luminol many people who
call themselves Catholics don't go to
church regularly but in Brazil when
people send their Protestants they go to
church at least once a week we seek to
welcome more than a million new members
into our community a significant s
another thousands and thousands of
Protestant churches here in Brazil
yachties dishes
and the suburbs of Rio de Janeiro the
evangelicals are in the ascendancy in
many communities there are more
Protestants and Catholics
the residence of Austin have a wide
choice of churches from liberal to
fundamentalist most of them are
Pentecostal parishes
livia dos Santos has been a member of
the prolific assembly of god for seven
years before that she followed the
afro-brazilian religion candle bleh and
conjured the spirits of her ancestors
both of her parents died when she was a
child her father was an alcoholic her
mother was stabbed to death by her new
lover Livia was brought up by relatives
broke with them when she was 15 and
became pregnant two years later
she might be that same hair I let a
wildlife I drank a lot messed around
with men and I didn't take care of my
children up I had no peace at home there
was always chaos and arguments until I
found Jesus who changed my life my
family my home at that kid we won't
reassess your zoosk removed or me start
and we'll donate familia he gave me
peace and to safe haven me throw support
I realized there's no way except the way
of God the family on or silk I'm
introduced the 32 year old goes to
church almost every evening the
parishioners are incredibly proud of
their church building the interior is
all new thanks to their donations
although the 100 members hardly have
enough to live on they give a tenth of
their income to the church in prayer
they call on the Holy Spirit to lead
their community the Spirit is the link
between them and God the Father and it's
the main focus of the Pentecostal
movement
they say the Holy Spirit descends on
believers gives them divine inspiration
and performs miracles curing the sick
the pastor plays a guitar he's a crane
driver by day and carries out his
ministry voluntarily he hasn't had any
theological training I think it is I oh
my gosh I'm is a very lively church yeah
yes I did I done it some [ __ ] over
nope will enjoy that's right they like
comes it is why feel at home here and
sometimes they're moved to tears when
God shows them he cares he speaks to
them it shows them their lives heavy
elahi to the Swiss toys there are
several guests preachers that's typical
of an evangelical service do not
underestimate the devil the Bible
teaches us don't give the devil any sway
this is the hour of the believer be
vigilant their faith emphasizes the
threat posed by the devil especially
when they are disobedient this is a
conservative parish women and men sit on
separate sides of the church they take
their bible study seriously and insist
on a literal interpretation one two
three the Lord shall fight for you you
need only to be still
then they pray for each person present
to exorcise the demons the devil who was
trying to take possession of them let
the enemies rage subside shouts the
preacher in this four and a half hour
service they have received the spiritual
armor they need for the next day's
troubles don't ever know much for it
gives us confidence strength and hope to
carry on gilmore all shaking many of us
go home and face problems with our
husbands or with the children we leave
the church encouraged equipped to cope
with daily life it strengthens our
spiritually sams like you my ish for
this is pretty close
in the fashionable business district of
barra da tijuca pastor sila smell a fire
has his own TV studio he drives to work
in an armored car his special force
bodyguards follow in a separate vehicle
for men in plain clothes who follow
behind him wherever he goes no como se
he said a mutiny assa I got lots of
threats from the gay lobby yummy i said
you kill me BJ up it'll move him into
gay I would have been attacked on three
occasions if I hadn't had my bodyguards
with me it would ask at the airport and
while Shawn had oh but I'll not be
intimidated by the way now I speak my
mind even more openly my xanga his faith
broadcast has been running for more than
30 years he studied theology has a
degree in psychology and is a media
expert if everything doesn't run to plan
he is liable to lose his temper allora
this is too much do I always have to
think of everything his secretary forgot
an important appointment shortly before
going to air he has to vent his anger ah
okay Baba bye-bye his weekly program
victory through Christ has made him
famous throughout Brazil its broadcast
on the public channels is repeated daily
and is financed completely by donations
even foreign commercial broadcasters
relay the program the basic idea is
mission to win as many converts to the
evangelical faith as possible and
preferably for his own church
before dia increased or go past or
Sheila's mala fire Lamia jamesy boy she
my dear people I want to speak to you
today about a very important subject
Xabi there are opportunities biish
Bibles don't waste them G spiritus I
don't throw them away of water yep bring
d learn to exploit your opportunities
half of the program consists of a
pre-recorded sermon Oprah geisha
oportunidad I preached about
opportunities all based on the Bible's
will be animal I preached about the
inner drive based on the bible school
bedico my diminished I preach about how
to manage your time based on the Bible I
try to preach not only a religious
message I think that's what makes
unusual I try to communicate a message
how people can apply in everyday life
applica navi dejare de pesos y IE he
himself takes an opportunity to sell
books odds yes I cameo I wrote this one
conquering God's blessing so that's five
bucks all together and i'll give you a
fifty percent discount santo de desconto
he sells more books than any other pasta
in brazil that's 1 million a year he
tells us proudly his publishing house
central gospel also prints bibles and
other religious literature in addition
he owns a record label he markets his
publications through his own call center
which also canvases sponsors for his TV
program in addition the pastor has set
up a foundation to finance charity work
it's a diversified financial empire an
American business magazine estimated
malla fires wolf at about 150 million
u.s. dollars and named him Brazil's
third richest pastor he sued the editors
he says his only worth about 2 million
dollars the millions he receives in
donations belong to the church he says
incidentally that way they're not taxed
he insists that his followers are his
only source of income they give him
money he says out of a sense of
financial responsibility and spiritual
conviction pacificus do you think people
are crazy a bunch of manipulated idiots
who pay out all their lives without ever
getting anything in return god works on
the principle of reward on that count he
himself has been richly rewarded he
began his working life selling crisps
from a minibus today he flies across the
country in a private jet opinion polls
rate him as one of the most influential
men in brazil and he has received
several awards for his socio-political
commitment i'll be sure to many fleas
yay my aim is to influence all areas of
life we should not be underestimated we
will not let minorities thrushes they
simply want to deny our rights we won't
accept that that's why I say we are a
bastion against abortion la wera bastion
against same-sex marriage we're a wall
Posada Livio dos Santos on the other
hand is fighting more existential
battles she dropped out of school and
never learned a trade she earns her
daily bread as a cleaner and says God
gives her the strength to work so that
her kids can have a better future a
tenth of her modest income goes to the
church for her it's a demonstration of
faith Wow of course it's pretty tight at
times at the end of the month when all i
have is the money for the church gave us
your levels have sought their words that
unsettles me he cannot get it what now
COC learning that's where faith comes to
water now I want you anthus or fair
Livia's faith helps her in difficult
situations and it has an influence on
the whole family boy mama when are we
going evangelizing hopefully up like in
a minute you can go and get ready every
free minute is for the church she
doesn't have any other social life this
weekend the parish is going out in small
groups to convert the neighbors there's
van been swallowed is god bless you and
here's an invitation you this don't want
visitarme and lost our church down there
on the corners having a party next week
if it is a Monica they they want to draw
people out of the bars and into the
church armed with flyers and missionary
spirit they managed to gain entry
everywhere what thou jesus loves you
okay a blessed Sunday their commitment
bears fruit many of the people here used
to go to church but then they fell prey
to alcohol and worldly pleasures
the evangelicals promise spiritual
comfort and practical advice but also
social order which is often lacking they
especially try to win young people liana
liberato gr8 kamiya pradesh Tenchi CC so
your valuable source for Jesus boiler
was the world sees you and says what a
bunch of criminals and good-for-nothings
but forgot your precious divorce a
songbirds preciosa spray sao paulo dada
Chicanos cannot agree it is Vega main
the people see that for us evangelicals
it's not important to go to church ally
God's work in the evangelical mission
are expansive and extend all the way out
here to a parade to mark the biggest
evangelical event of the year in the
center of Rio de Janeiro hundreds of
thousands of people gather for the Jesus
March as vice president of the
interdenominational Council of
evangelical church ministers in Brazil
Zeila smell of fire is in charge
many observers believe that the
evangelicals with their rapid growth
will soon overtake Catholics as the
largest religious community in Brazil
I'm happy this shows the unity and
strength of the evangelical church
politicians take part men who hope to
channel this power most of them are
members of the church anzhela smell a
fire supports them the evangelical
church represents 15 million votes with
their votes these people could decide a
presidential election change their
communities even the whole country
pastor Silas knows how to influence
people by myself was elected on his
recommendation there's no doubt that it
helps that the church and healthy way
and separated from the state can
influence decision-making in our country
they have the second most powerful lobby
in Brazil's Chamber of Deputies while
marching into Rio's symbolic carnival
arena they proclaim their intention to
grow Brazil is shifting to the right
with the growth of the Pentecostal
churches and the new lower middle class
the number of conservatives is
increasing hello people of God the theme
of our March this year is for the family
and for us a family means a man a woman
and their children in supporting
traditional marriage they oppose
same-sex unions the guests politicians
also address the crowds the most
powerful hardliner from the conservative
evangelical camp Eduardo Cunha president
of Brazil's Chamber of Deputies is under
investigation for corruption and money
laundering he's accused of taking five
million dollars in bribes to secure
contracts with oil company Petrobras
and then gospel stars take the stage
evangelical artists dominate rozilla
kindess tree and entertain millions
their songs help to win masses of new
converts
the traditional Protestant churches such
as the Lutheran's are not profiting from
this evangelizing boom more than half of
the Protestants in Brazil belonged to
the Pentecostal movement the Brazilian
lutheran church is just one of many
splinter groups within the country's
Protestant church the president of the
national council of christian churches
works hard to promote church unity but
thorny social issues such as what to do
about the country's widespread poverty
divide the churches the evangelicals
don't address these controversial
questions they have a different focus
thang SI character is the moon to mark
one characteristic is the theology of
prosperity the accumulating of wealth
mahadji and frankly also the
exploitation of people's extreme need ah
the missus is i don't want people turn
to them in despair and there they try to
find the hole cause of their happiness
or unhappiness in the individual person
don't see their told if you're suffering
poverty it's because you don't know how
to manage your life properly por que vou
sair no possibility mistress ravi de
direito the theologian campus Garcia is
also a lawyer and an expert on human
rights she's critical of the evangelical
movement including its influence on the
media with its own TV channels radio
stations and online platforms sylla's
malla fire also promotes populist
evangelical views on his website
trouncing the gay liberation movement
for instance so for example says ikea
neshama called me homophobic ah past
your night you a reactionary I can't bad
you know those were journalists my
friend there is pressure to force
homosexual behavior on society as if
someone were born homosexual Wow como
que NOS estamos x wrong tell me the
genetic proof there's a social imbalance
we are the balanced ones
the good that still creates order in
society though this is the strokes of
all this polemical stuff against
homosexuals is really homophobia it's a
theology of exclusion zone the
evangelicals are seriously harming
Brazil Oberon's you pokey for instance
all the Human Rights achievements of the
past 12 years are under threat nauseas
islami Asada's
but in the suburbs of Rio de Janeiro
this religious and social shift is
mostly viewed positively it has eased
daily misery and the evangelicals are
proud of their success we're a marvel
used to be murdered for nothing they
were constant battles well they
sodomized today the people talk to each
other more and seek dialogue the event
tentacles have brought some peace into
the world the mission drive ends with a
religious service it draws a big crowd
including many people who had left the
church
your vamp go wash I've come although i'm
completely dirty but I said I need to
call my heart told me to or not bailey
i'm trying to decide whether to join
again because there's nothing better
than being there with God George give us
asylum why does somebody want to come to
Jesus come here there's one but that's
all for today just this one person and
it was worth it today the pasta receives
the new convert into the church father
your lost son was far from you but today
he's seen that he cannot stay far away
and it's oh cuz of this office we reach
people who have left the church we bring
them back it's not about gaining
converts for a particular church our
mission is to spread the message of God
and Christ so that the people commit to
it and follow the way of the Lord please
get is Beyonce Thai stick your tongue in
the same
God is with you they sing Livia and her
fellow evangelicals with his help they
want to change Brazil into a country
committed to Jesus